hey guys it is Friday today which you
probably already knew but you might not
know all the cool things that happened
in gaming this week so I'm going to fill
you in on that front first up Destiny's
creative story lead had left Bungie
after 13 years CJ cohen announced his
departure on his social media channels
explaining after 13 years i decided to
part ways with bungie Cohen didn't
clarify his reasons for leaving or what
he plans to do next he joined the
company in 2003 when he worked on Halo 2
as a cinematic designer after which he
became director of cinematics for Halo 3
Halo 3 ODST and in the reach Destiny's
next massive update is due to land on
April 12 bringing new quests bounty the
gear and tweaks to weapon balancing
among other things another massive
update landing on April 12 is for the
division and hear everything you'll
probably want to know about that the
patch notes for the update were released
earlier this week and aside from the
introduction of the divisions first raid
Ubisoft are making a lots of changes to
how much high-end gear will cost you to
fly and craft what level you'll need to
be to apply a certain items and changes
to the way loot drops new features also
include gear sets player trading weekly
and daily assignments supply drops in
the dark zone and new high-end named
weapons next up Square Enix has
clarified that the format of Final
Fantasy 7 remake will be a number of
full-sized games and not small episodes
producer Yoshinori quitarse told Game
Informer that each part which comprises
Final Fantasy 7 remake will be equal to
the scale of final fantasy 13 adding
that it won't be an episodic series he
explained that they also plan to change
certain elements of the story to improve
it although they won't be changing
everything so far no release date has
been announced for the remake this week
Sony released update 3.5 for the ps4 and
here
all the new [ __ ] you can do with it yeah
small owners will now be able to appear
offline being notified when friends come
online gentle user events and join
parties with a group of friends to make
multiplayer sessions easier you're also
now able to use your ps4 via remote play
on a Mac or PC which if people I follow
on Twitter are correct is actually
working surprisingly well you can check
out the full list of new features in our
story on gamespot finally game
developers still don't like it when you
pirate their games and remedy have
Illustrated that once again in quantum
break reddit user disaster discovered
that if the game detects you're running
a pirated copy it gives protagonist Jack
Joyce an eyepatch like with a pirate
skull on it and everything some of you
may have found that this occurs even if
you do have a legit copy which could be
because you aren't logged into your
Microsoft account while playing rember
you're known for this kind of
light-hearted pirate branding as they
did the same thing with their last block
buster Alan Wake let me know down in the
comments what you cared about this week
and if you've been taking advantage of
any of the new ps4 feature this week on
site we review had the light drifter as
well as the HTC vive and we check out
steam early access game who's your daddy
that is everything I have for you this
week but be sure to have yourself a
lovely weekend and I will see you again
on Monday